el triángulo p y n se rota menos 270
grados alrededor del origen
este es el triángulo p y n traza la
imagen de esta rotación utilizando la
gráfica interactiva la dirección de una
rotación con un ángulo positivo es en el
sentido contrario a las manecillas del
reloj
entonces positivo es en el sentido
contrario a las manecillas del reloj es
una convención estándar y esto aquí
tenemos un ángulo negativo menos 270
como es un ángulo negativo sería en el
sentido de las manecillas del reloj su
rotación así que aquí vamos a usar una
herramienta y con esta herramienta yo
puedo colocar puntos donde yo quiera y
también puedo quitarlos arrastrándolos y
poniéndolos aquí en el bote de reciclaje
ahora queremos pensar en que si rotamos
los puntos de este triángulo alrededor
del origen menos 270 grados donde van a
terminar estos puntos después de hacer
la rotación y para pensar en ello lo que
hice fue copiar y pegar esta
esta imagen del ejercicio en una
herramienta de dibujo aquí está entonces
primero pensemos en que es una rotación
de menos 270 grados y para esto para
pensar en esto voy a dibujar unos ejes
coordinados entonces pensemos en qué es
una rotación de menos 270 grados aquí
están los ejes coordinados
tenemos aquí el eje de las equis y acá
el eje de la yes entonces voy a empezar
supongamos que empezamos empezamos aquí
entonces rotamos alrededor del origen
menos 270 grados esto sería el origen
y entonces qué sucede si rotamos en esta
dirección que es en el sentido de las
manecillas del reloj tenemos menos 90
grados y si rotamos otra vez tenemos
otros menos 90 grados en total menos 180
si volvemos a rotar tenemos aquí otros
menos 90 grados que serían un total de
menos 270 grados entonces esto es menos
270 grados nota que esto nos lleva hasta
este punto pero también pudimos haber
llegado aquí solo rotando 90 grados
positivos esto es 90 grados positivos
entonces quieren que rotamos estos
puntos menos 270 grados alrededor del
origen pero eso es equivalente a
solamente rotar todos estos puntos 90
grados positivos sólo me voy a enfocar
en los puntos de él de este triángulo en
los vértices para poderlo visualizar un
poco mejor
entonces vamos a rotar cada uno de estos
puntos 90 grados positivos alrededor del
origen como hacemos eso para hacer eso
lo que haré es dibujar una serie de
triángulos rectángulos primero nos vamos
a enfocar en el vértice y de este
triángulo entonces voy a dibujar un
triángulo rectángulo que podría dibujar
de diferentes maneras pero voy a
dibujarlo así así que este va a ser uno
de los lados este otro y la línea que va
del origen al vértice y esta hipotenusa
de ese triángulo rectángulo así que esta
es la hipotenusa del triángulo
rectángulo y si yo voy a rotar 90 grados
positivos alrededor del origen eso es
equivalente a rotar este triángulo 90
grados entonces qué va a pasar aquí si
yo roto
vamos a tomar primero este lado si yo
roto este lado 90 grados lo voy a
dibujar con color rosa
si yo roto este lado 90 grados a dónde
irá este lado del triángulo una vez que
lo rote bueno pues en lugar de estar 7
unidades sobre el eje
x ahora estará siete unidades sobre el
eje de las yes porque los rote 90 grados
aquí estará ese lado si los rotas 90
grados positivos es el lado del
triángulo se mirará así es rotar los 90
grados entonces que hay ahora con este
el lado del triángulo rectángulo que
está en azul que hay con ese lado bueno
pues para este lado nota que estamos
bajando del origen siete unidades pero
si lo rotamos 90 grados positivos como
aquí se forma un ángulo recto entre el
lado rosa y el lado azul entonces vamos
a tener también acá un ángulo recto
desde este punto así que de aquí vamos a
seguir siete unidades a la derecha y
este sería el punto y la imagen
correspondiente al punto y después de la
rotación sería este y ese sería la
hipotenusa así que después de tener este
triángulo rectángulo y rotar los 90
grados positivos
alrededor del origen después de rotar
los 90 grados positivos el nuevo punto
sería este que llamaremos y prima
entonces hagamos esto con el vértice n y
el vértice p sigamos con el vértice n
voy a dibujar un triángulo rectángulo
donde la hipotenusa el lado que va del
origen al vértice n esa es la hipotenusa
del triángulo rectángulo este sería uno
de los lados y este sería el otro y voy
a rotar este triángulo rectángulo 90
grados positivos entonces donde quedara
este lado que va del origen 7 unidades
hacia abajo después de rotar los 90
grados estará 7 unidades sobre el eje de
las x a la derecha ahí va a quedar y
después de este lado
que mide dos unidades aquí se formó un
ángulo recto entonces al rotarlo aquí se
forma un ángulo recto entonces el lado
de dos unidades sube aquí dos unidades y
ya tenemos con esto con esto la imagen
del vértice n aquí está la hipotenusa
del triángulo rectángulo aquí se forma
la hipotenusa del triángulo rectángulo
entonces este es el nuevo vértice n
llamaremos en el prima a este nuevo
vértice que sería la imagen del vértice
n entonces ahora sigue el vértice p hago
lo mismo voy a dibujar un triángulo
rectángulo
ahí está el triángulo rectángulo que
vamos a rotar 90 grados positivos
entonces voy a tomar uno de sus lados
vamos a tomar este lado de dos unidades
este mide dos unidades
aquí está entonces bueno este lado lo
vamos a rotar 90 grados positivos
entonces en lugar de ser sobre el eje de
las equis va a estar ahora sobre el eje
de las yes ahora voy a tomar este lado
que mide 3 unidades y nota que aquí se
formó un ángulo recto entonces al
rotarlo acá también se va a formar un
ángulo recto y es el lado que mide 3
unidades va a quedar justo aquí entonces
ya lo tenemos aquí está la hipotenusa
del triángulo rectángulo y este es el
nuevo vértice p prima lo vamos a llamar
que es la imagen del vértice p y ya con
esto solamente nos falta conectar los
puntos p prima y prima y n prima para
ver cuál es la imagen del triángulo p y
n después de la rotación
entonces ya los conecto y ahí ya tenemos
la imagen del triángulo p y en hora
solamente vamos a ingresar esto al
problema original
entonces el vértice p prima tiene
coordenadas menos 3
así que vamos a ingresar esto al
problema original menos 32 sería el
vértice prima
ahora vamos con el vértice en el pri
tiene coordenadas 72 entonces lo ingreso
aquí 72 es n prima y el vértice y tiene
coordenadas 77 77 entonces lo ingreso el
vértice y prima está aquí en 77 y
después doy clic en el vértice prima
para conectar y completar el triángulo y
ya habré rotado un ángulo de 90 grados o
lo que es equivalente menos 270 grados